if you were the last person on earth
like everybody disappeared everybody's
dead
uh
what would your day look like what would
your days look like what would you do
that's interesting because if i was able
to figure out the you know
electricity
right i think my days would be like why
didn't you learn about electricity oh
yeah right you realize how little you
know yeah yeah why didn't you learn
about these things because now you're
gonna die yeah right yeah but i think
the first thing obviously is
now let me ask you something why
now if you're saying that um i'm the
last person on planet earth because
there was an alien invasion and there's
predators and things that i have to
[ __ ] look out for that's one way but
if i'm just all of a sudden i wake up
and just everyone's gone
and there's everyone's dead everyone's
dead but there's no threat there's no
threat then what i would do is i go
well let's find
a place to live not probably my house
right so i probably live in a place
where that's closest to
grocery stores
right so i would get food and stuff
first right and then secondly it's like
you know i'll probably go you know what
i've thought about i would probably go
to um san marcos
san diego vista because that's where the
real doll factory is they just [ __ ] all
of them no no i would have to grab like
six of them because i'm gonna get lonely
six of them for a variety you wouldn't
be monogamous with one doll no and no
and i also would carry out like the the
you know the vagina parts you know and
all the accessories and stuff right yeah
and then go back to la probably oh man
why would i stay down there you could
stay in the factory no yeah maybe it's
that factory and then um but i think
thirdly i would run out of electricity
right and i think you know i mean my
demise would come slow well you could
find sources of electricity because
nobody's using it
so i don't know how to turn the machines
on like i don't know how to go to the
[ __ ] um
yeah
what do you already what do you call it
the place where it's i don't even know
what it's called
the place where you don't mean where it
all
the energy is generated yeah the
generators like where do i go
you